merci nous partons maintenant à la
découverte du goût chaque année depuis 7
ans pendant une semaine des cuisiniers
des nutritionnistes tente de redonner à
nos enfants le goût des bons produits au
pays de la meilleure cuisine du monde ce
matin en banlieue parisienne une classe
s'est promené dans les rayons légumes
d'un grand magasin avant de se diriger
vers les cuisines d'un grand hôtel
reportage eric lemasson dominique beaune
les maternelle grande section sont en
balade voyage initiatique dans les
rayons du supermarché au pays des fruits
et légumes
c'est la semaine du goût l'ambition est
noble pourfendre le fast-food lutter
contre la démission gastronomique de
parents trop pressé alors on reprend
tout depuis le début
leçon de choses travaux pratiques car
quand on a 5 ans c'est bien que ça fait
grandir mais on les confond un peu tous
ces légumes quels autres légumes tu
connais leur réaction face aux légumes
qu'ils connaissent pas complètement
naturel
ils vont prendre des légumes y vont
immédiatement d'abord il est ou s'ils
vont les prendre dans la main c'est vrai
qu'après ils écoutent totalement
spontanément c'est vraiment spontané et
en général on a très très bonne surprise
les formes contiennent dans ce grand
hôtel parisien aussi ans qu'on célèbre
la semaine du goût le chef pâtissier et
viennois les élèves vivent dans le 16e
mais l'initiation aux subtilités du goût
est tout aussi nécessaire
comment s'y prendre un sondage réalisé
pour l'occasion montrent que les
français ont l'habitude de forcer leurs
enfants ainsi 64% des français ont été
contraints dans leur enfance de manger
des légumes
ils sont encore 60% à forcer leurs
propres enfants
car ce n'est pas simple de faire
découvrir sans contraindre à - d'initier
dès le plus jeune âge
beaucoup d'enfants qui ont battus jamais
mangé la cannelle donc faire
connaissance des épices de s'échange 13
secondes au lieu de qui trouve plaisirs
salés
ah non j'aime pas tout ça pour qu'il
développe le goût
il faut les a butées des tout petits
brins nos maternelles achèvent leurs
travaux pratiques
c'est l'heure de goûter la soupe velouté
de chou fleur c'est le cuisinier qui l'a
préparé et c'est un succès mais le rayon
des soupes tout près ce n'est pas loin
un rayon qui ne cesse de s'agrandir 10
mètres de longueur
car la vraie soupe est bonne mais les
mamans n'ont plus le temps éplucher les
légumes
une amie